Hello and welcome to fire learning.
Contrary to some belief whom is not just
a fancy way of saying who there is in
fact a grammatical difference.
And in this video we're going to
take a look at that difference.
The simple answer between the difference
of the two is that who is used as a
subject and meaning it's used as
the doer of an action in a sentence.
While whom is the receiver of that action,
the object of a verb or proposition.
Let's look at some
sentences here for example,
who who is cleaning their car and this
sentence we're looking for the doer of
declining.
Therefore who who is washing fire of
learning and this sentence we are looking
for again,
who is doing the watching,
who is yelling at him and this sentence
we're looking for who is doing the
yelling.
However to flip it around the bed we
can employ whom to the same well similar
sentence at whom is he yelling?
Because the person in question
is not the one doing the yelling,
but the one being yelled at
the correct word here is whom?
For the more notice we said at whom,
not whom.
It's yelling ads because it's improper
to end a sentence with a preposition,
but that's a topic for a future video.
For whom are we looking here,
the focus is on the individual
for which the subject is looking,
not the person doing the looking.
Whom do you believe? Here again,
we're not asking who
is doing the believing,
but we're asking about
the person being believed.
One helpful tip to remembering
this concept is simply
if who can be replaced by
here,
she then use who however I can if it
can be replaced by him or her use home.
Take a look at these sentences,
which one is correct.
All right,
now try these.
If you answered B for both of them, then
you're getting the hang of it. If not,
just keep working at it.
It's perfectly understandable if it takes
a second to understand considering the
fact that we actually make this
mistake a lot in common speech,
I make the mistake and common
conversation all the time.
I've probably made a mistake
plenty of times and my past videos,
but it's very important to understand
English and be able to use it well.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
be sure to check out Fiverr of learning
and subscribe. Thank you for watching.